if you had a day where nobody would  recognize you I don't think I'd be that  different honestly I I operate I I  dropped the whole trying to be something  for somebody a long time ago so I I  pretty much walk through the world  except when I want to be funnier I want  to do something outrageous you know kind  of tip the boat you know I don't have  any trouble being myself and I don't  have any trouble saying no when I mean  no when I don't feel there is a you know  pressing uh responsibility to please  everyone I'm not unkind to people I love  people I would much prefer saying hello  and who are you and what are you doing  today and then giving a selfie because  selfies stop the world you know they  stop life you then go all right yeah and  it's going on Instagram to give people a  false sense of relevance